hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in book six of his lives of the
philosophers diogenes liertas tells
us about the cynics and among them
diogenes who's probably in ancient times
and
in our own times the most famous of the
school of the cynic some people think he
might have been the first
others including diogenes laertes say
that he was a student
of socrates student antisthenes who was
the first
of the cynic school it doesn't really
matter that much when we think about the
way of life
that diogenes was living
because he provides a kind of model
and you know sort of a a
character that stands in for cynicism
throughout the ages by all reports he
had
a number of students including the very
famous
krates who would become the teacher of
zeno the founder of stoicism
as well as a number of other students
including hipparchia who marries
krates and one of the things that the
cynics were really known for
is stressing the simplicity
of life having a way of living
that one wouldn't starve and one you
know wouldn't lose
fingers or toes to frostbite or things
like that you could live a
decent life but one that was not
you could say dependent upon all of the
needs and desires that the ordinary
person
has a life in which one's wants could be
satisfied
fairly easily and there's some stories
told about
how diogenes himself learns
from children the example of children he
says
one day observing a child drinking out
of his hands he cut he cast away the cup
from his wallet with the words a child
has beaten me
in plainness or simplicity of living
eutelea
he also threw away his bowl when in like
manner he saw a child who had broken his
plate
taking up his lentils with the hollow
part of a morsel
of bread so he sees these examples of
people and you might even say animals
being able to live a life
where whatever they have is going to be
satisfactory whatever they have is going
to suffice
and he you know breaks things down to a
very
simple kit he has a cloak
and the cynics were known for this for
doubling up their cloak
or sleeping in their cloak a wallet
or you know we don't think of like a
little tiny wallet think of like a
container that you carry by your side
a staff later on in life when he needs
it he also
uses it for things you know and then
he's quite famous for having had a tub
now he actually did apply to somebody to
buy him a small house
but the person was delaying and so
instead of wait around for him he found
essentially a barrel
and you can see that in the famous
paintings of diogenes
and he used that as his as we call them
nowadays tiny house
and so that was sufficient for him when
uh one of the boys in athens actually
broke his barrel they punished him and
they gave him another barrel
to live in as well and he's got this
great
phrase that sort of describes the way
of life that he's living both in terms
of its simplicity
and in terms of the other features of it
he says
this is diogenes laertes on diogenes the
cynic
he claimed that to fortune
touhey lock chance he could oppose
here it has courage but a better
translation is
confidence thoros the feeling that one
can get by
no matter what no matter what the luck
or
fate or fortune is going to throw in
one's lap you have the resources
to deal with that to convention
nomo in this case uh he opposes
nature fusing and we'll come back to
that in just a moment
to passion uh pathe
logo reason so
this is actually worth dwelling on quite
a bit convention
it can also be translated as customer
law these
are the ways of living and the
prescribed
social duties and expectations
that go with any community that you
belong to
and this is a constant concern in greek
philosophy
how much of life should be nomos
or convention how much of it should be
phusis or
nature when he says nature he doesn't
mean
as we often say oh well that's human
nature to excuse people's bad behavior
although diogenes does behave in some
ways that some of us
might consider bad it means the
developed
nature of a human being
the nature that we ought to have same
thing with passion right this is
covering more than just
like you say oh somebody's passionate
about something
this covers the emotions this covers the
desires and aversions
this covers all of these sorts of things
that move
us that make us their prey
that drive us into things like eros you
know erotic desire
for one thing we can oppose to that
logos which means
reason but also speech we can reason
with ourselves
and say no no no let's not go along with
this and that's going to be
discussed a little bit later in terms of
pleasure
for the most part he ate you know fairly
simple
fair when it came to food he even tried
to eat
raw meat but he found that he couldn't
simplify
things quite so far that doesn't mean
that he wouldn't eat or drink
good stuff when he could get it he was
asked at one point what the best kind of
wine is and he said
that which you can get for free what
people are going to give to you
right and he's also asked at another
point will the wise meaning you
eat honey cakes and he says why wouldn't
they but they're not going to go
looking for that if somebody happens to
give it to him
great if nobody happens to give it to
him also great
so he's not going to be like many people
you know a gourmand
pursuing that there's a long discussion
at least long for diogenesis about
training or ascasis which is well worth
looking at he tells us that
both mental or or
psychical you could say uh it's a
sukicane or an and bodily somatic cane
training
are necessary so mental
training allows us with constant
exercise
to form perceptions fantasy
things that we we imagine or we perceive
that secure freedom of movement for
virtuous deeds that
allow us to
be our better selves you could say so
having the right frame of mind
practicing with the right ideas
so that we can in fact free ourselves up
for doing
the good things doing the right things
that's an important
part of training he also says
that you also need bodily training
without it good health and strength
being just as much
included among the essential things
whether for body or soul
and he says he would induce indisputable
evidence to show how easily
from gymnastic training we arrive
at virtue and here's here's his argument
in the manual crafts and the other arts
the tech day
it can be seen that the crafts people
develop extraordinary manual skill
through practice
same thing with flute players same thing
with athletes by working and working and
working at it
they change their habits they change
their mind they change their body
and so he says if they transfer their
efforts to the training of the mind
how certainly their labors would not
have been unprofitable
or ineffective so we can determine
whether we're going to be happy in life
or not by the kind of training
that we do he also says that
nothing can can succeed without
strenuous practice this is capable of
overcoming
anything so we need to be careful about
what it is
that we're setting our hands to are we
going to focus
on learning skills that aren't really
profitable to us
are we going to develop habits that are
not going to lead us
in any helpful direction or are we going
to pick other things so he talks about
useless toils uh you know things that we
do
that are that are difficult or you know
the pronoun in in greek
he says we should choose those that are
natural
cataphusine in greek in accordance with
nature in accordance with our nature
and why should we choose them in order
ultimately to be happy right
in order to enjoy as he's got it here
eudaimonia a good state of mind
for our lives and there's a really
interesting
but short discussion there about
changing our habits
so that we can despise pleasure
he says that even despising pleasure is
itself
most pleasurable when we're habituated
to it
just as those accustomed to a life of
pleasure feel disgust when they pass
over to the
opposite experience those whose training
has been of the opposite kind
derive more pleasure from deriving
pleasure than from the pleasures
themselves so if you want to have a
really pleasant life
self-control despising meaning looking
down upon
it's not being approved or anything like
that but the the word is cataphronin
which is to look down
at as if you're above it despising the
kinds of pleasures that other people
are motivated by there's also
discussions
about him using statues in two important
ways
one has to do with a kind of accustoming
himself
to difficulties so hugging statues in
the winter
the statues are cold and hard and so you
harden up your body by
doing that he also would like lay out in
the sun in the hot you know the hot
summer
and do other stuff like walk barefoot on
you know hot
areas all of that was to toughen the
body
but there's a very interesting practice
that he also had
with statues he would beg alms from them
now you say what's that about is he just
being kind of a
silly drama queen no he would beg alms
from them
and say this is so that when i ask real
people
i'm not going to be so upset when they
say
no to me i'll get used to people acting
like statues as people do this day when
you know they walk past a homeless
person
and they just ignore them right the
homeless person is asking them
for something so using the statues in
two different ways is kind of
interesting
diogenes also set convention aside quite
a bit this is another word for this that
diogenes liertes talks about is debasing
or defacing
the currency which is what either
diogenes himself
or his dad got in trouble for in cenop
he's defacing it in a different way
taking the customary things that people
do
and violating those social customs the
probably
one of the most egregious examples
that's recorded
in diogenes lier taste is masturbating
in the marketplace
and then when he gets called on it
saying if only hunger was so easy to
satisfy
i would just rub my belly instead
but he also eats in the marketplace
which was apparently kind of a no-no
at the time in the agora right the place
where everybody
would gather together there's also some
interesting stories about
carrying food so there's a story about
somebody
dropping a loaf of bread and being
ashamed or embarrassed to pick it up and
diogenes in order to like you know
make a point about this he ties a
wine jar to a bit of rope and drags it
behind himself
calling attention to what he's doing
this ridiculous
action he also at one point this is
there's a couple stories about this
told about cynics he gives um
somebody a fish a big old fish and
has him carry it across the marketplace
the guy won't do it and he says well
you you threw our friendship away
because you're too ashamed to carry a
fish i guess you don't value it that
much
so these are you know kind of
interesting actions that we can talk
about
and we can close on you know another
thing that he says that i think is
really
quite good that sums up the
cynic attitude has to do with the kind
of life
that we we live right when someone
declared that
life is an evil that life is bad
he corrected him he said it's not life
itself that's bad
it's living poorly or
living ill living badly
um cacos in this as an adjective
in the greek and so you know that's a
really great way to think about it it's
life is what we make of it the cynics
decide that they're going to make of it
a way to truly be happy they call this
the royal
road to happiness it's a very difficult
path to pursue but diogenes thought that
he was helping out
his fellow members of athens he's not
actually an athenian
himself but doing something similar to
what socrates is doing
trying to call people's attention back
to what's really
important and to tell them that their
priorities are off and to do so
precisely by the way that he's living
you could say
if diogenes can do it maybe i can do it
too
and so we have the possibility of not
living badly but instead
living a happy life following the
cynic way of living that diogenes
perhaps
took to one of its extremes
you